[Music]
it's a very long walk up to the
children's world and you do get time to
think of
what we're gonna see when we get there
nicole renshaw is a mental health nurse
and her patients are children most of
the time the children
have harmed themselves and there are
children on the ward most days
while the nation's been fighting a virus
that's killed
so many thousands of children have been
suffering
and the problem has been slowly and
silently building
this is the children's ward of the royal
oldham hospital
and this is 14 year old laura
she's here because she's deliberately
harmed herself
often children will self-harm or harm
themselves in other ways
to deal with stressful situations and
in laura's case that has definitely been
a factor
laura's mum says her daughter hasn't
been herself for a while now
she doesn't come out of her room she
doesn't eat much
she needs a help she needs professional
help
well i go through depression as well and
it comes and goes whenever it feels like
it
so i know what she's going through her
pain is so raw
and i can see the fear in her face what
do you want to happen now
i just want her back to normal how she
used to be smiling laughing joking
i have to understand to make sure that
you're safe
life at home in lockdown has been tough
i've never really gone out as much so is
that normal for you to be sitting in
your bedroom all day long
not usually i'm usually outside with
people but i think
it happened and numb since guava the
divorce center
reclused into the bedrooms and now
she stopped eating like i'm either too
busy to eat or i'm doing something and
i'll just leave about forget about it
and wait for later
so just don't bother and how long has
that been going on for
quite a while right our next bit mummy
you're listening
we need to get a safe hour lock on a
drawer all medication
sharps ligatures need to be in that box
okay and then nicole
gently tries to give laura something to
live for
you want to go to college yeah
you want to go to uni yeah i want you to
hold on to that
because it can be done
before the pandemic a e attendances by
children with psychiatric conditions
had tripled in the last 10 years
now month on month those numbers are
continuing to rise
she said she was going to kill herself
looks like she's assaulting mum
quite frequently this is children and
adolescent
mental health services or calms for
short
a child who's been in a e for mental
health reasons has to be seen here
within seven days
and it's in these rooms that they try to
heal
the minds of children we've spent three
weeks here
with unique access to staff and patients
to understand
the pressure the service is under have
you ever done anything like this before
yeah yeah well it started in year
seven hours of class so it's not only
for a few days it's been
it's been six years so it's been for a
couple of years
this is summer she was in a week ago
after harming herself now mental health
practitioner michelle
has to figure out what help she needs
yesterday in english i was like happy
and then like as soon as i went in
spanish i was just crying my eyes out i
literally got sent out
summer explains that her mood can swing
from high to low
so the last time summer south hound was
like yesterday did you say
um are they on board your own summer
just one just one hour
okay so i saw you yeah you can do yeah
so they don't what's that in your hand
what that
yeah it's a scratching scratch i have it
there as well
right okay okay i wish i didn't do it
like thought these are gonna be scars
now
but um i just regret it nothing
it's thought around a quarter of all
children summer's age have self-harmed
it could be much more than that
the cams team is now dealing with a
surge
in referrals self-harm suicide attempts
anxiety it is a grim but growing
list of troubles dr chantal bassen is
the lead clinical psychologist here
and she's worried about the effect the
pandemic has had on some children
there is going to be a section of people
in our society
who are kind of surviving through this
now and are in total survival mode
and as we come out of the pandemic that
we're more likely to see the mental
health impact
on those young people and families i
think we might be feeling the tremors
but i think
the impact may well yet to be seen
summer is now being supported by the
cams team
here at pennine care
it could be a long careful process
but thousands of youngsters are having
to wait to get to this stage
and for children in crisis there is
often no
time to spare
nick martin sky news